i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like my days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
andrew is a great friend of ours has
this big business called tiny uh where
they own a bunch of different businesses
north of 100 million ish or so in
revenue took a company public
you're whatever you're successful
in terms of career and traditional sense
of successful you're a good friend you
normally come on a lot but you just
tweeted how you kind of like took off
for all of august and you kind of bailed
because you were kind of having a
meltdown in which we all have had before
like a digital overload meltdown
uh and you just bailed right totally it
was really uh it was bad i mean it's
interesting to think about like i think
this happened to everyone over kovid
like their life just shifted in a weird
way um and my life just became crappy
over covid which is
weird because i had this amazing year
like we took a business public we raised
a big fund we got to work with all these
interesting people we bought some great
businesses i didn't die of covid like
all these great things happened and yet
i was totally miserable um and when i
look at it when i kind of zoom out my
old day
i don't know if you guys you guys know
but i live in victoria canada and i
didn't even have an office so i actually
liked just working out of cafes i would
just go to the same cafe every day
and i'd sit there with headphones on
three or four of my friends would always
work there so it's kind of like cheers
there's always like interesting people
to talk to
and my day was just broken up into a
bunch of chunks so
any given day i wouldn't really be on
the computer or in one place for more
than an hour or two and my day went from
that to
sitting in a house on my computer all
day on zoom and doing email
and it just kind of made me miserable
and so
i i am
you know when i look at like what i love
about business i don't actually love
you know doing business is great doing
strategy coming up with ideas all that
kind of stuff but the cool thing about
business is you get to meet interesting
people like business is just a hack
right so like if you're interested in
health you figure out like a health
business you suddenly can meet all the
most interesting people in that world um
and i'm an extrovert so anyway just i
was totally bummed and i started um you
know going on twitter a lot because i
was craving socializing um i and i i
went from like 20 000 followers to 170
000 followers so
i got totally hooked into that and like
a good day would be like i have a viral
tweet or i go on your podcast or
something something exciting happens a
bad day would be i say something on
twitter i get dunked on i got
misunderstood or it doesn't do well like
what a ridiculous thing like i'd tweet
and it would only get like 50 likes
instead of 5000 likes it would like
throw my day off so i got to a point
where i was just like jesus christ like
this is totally ridiculous i'm thinking
about twitter constantly i'm checking
twitter constantly and on top of that
i'm you know email
uh you know checking stats stocks uh if
i went to the bathroom without my phone
i feel like i feel i feel like i was
going to freak out constantly listening
to audio books constantly listening to
pod podcasts no silence so i just like
hit this weird breaking point august 1st
where i woke up
and i was like i'm not stoked to get her
to bed i'm not depressed objectively
everything is fine i'm like i'm just
like i have like anhedonia like i'm just
not excited about anything so i just
said it i'm just gonna what what
what's that word you just said that was
a good one
it means like an inability to feel
pleasure right like not
nothing would get me pumped nothing
would give me a hit
like you know you know when you like
you're always you go on netflix you're
like scrolling endlessly for the perfect
thing you just can't find it that's how
my life felt
and so i basically you know is the
middle august i live in british columbia
it's super beautiful and so i just said
to my wife you know what i'm out for the
next month let's just go off to our
cabin we'll you know we'll go on some
trips and i'm just going to totally
check out and i set a couple rules for
myself i was like no phone no email no
computer no podcasts uh no phone calls
no social media no news i couldn't even
read nonfiction business books right so
it's pretty extreme
and i put on my apple watch which has
you know cellular so i was like okay if
there's an emergency i can get a phone
call and i put my phone in a drawer and
i just disappeared i went up to my cabin
and hung out with my kids and honestly
for the first like three or four days it
felt like there was like a bug in my
brain like i was just like so like like
something i i itch i couldn't scratch
like just so irritable as being a huge
uh i was like slapping my pocket every
five seconds to check stuff i'd be
sitting on the beach with my kids and
i'd constantly be like oh i need to text
this to a friend i gotta i gotta take a
photo of this right so it's really weird
horrible withdrawal but then after like
three or four days i was like holy crap
like this is really interesting i
started reading fiction books and just
sitting for hours
uh you know enjoying a sunset taking a
silent drive doing all this stuff and i
think it's kind of like if you eat junk
food all the time like you're drinking
coke and having burgers and stuff all
the time and then you eat broccoli it
doesn't taste that good your brain is
primed for like these extreme flavors
and then if you switch to broccoli you
know you don't eat those things for a
month then you eat broccoli broccoli is
like orgasmic it's amazing and so anyway
i did this for four weeks and i was
feeling really good
and i came back to life like i kind of
reintroduced myself into society and
started going out and working and stuff
and it was really bizarre like i you
know would listen to a song that was
playing in a cafe and it'd be like the
greatest song i've ever heard i'd read
some random article and it would be like
fascinating and i'd just be completely
uh like just
you know engaged with it um and then
problems i had to solve that would have
pissed me off like seemed like no
problem when i was excited to solve them
and i was kind of going like man why why
did that work like what was it about
that
and at the same time like around then i
started listening to podcasts again
and i listen to this podcast
by uh andrew huberman huberman lab which
i'm sure you guys have listened to he's
amazing yeah he's uh he's coming on the
podcast oh amazing that's that's awesome
so he did this deep dive on addiction
and he did it with this woman anna lemke
who's a
stanford addiction doctor and i was like
oh this will be interesting it'll be
about like heroin addiction or something
and how they treat alcoholism so i'll
start listening to it those other people
who have those other bad problems
it's fun it's fun to read about them
totally i was like i was like oh this
will be you know maybe philanthropic you
know i can help fund the heroin
addiction center in victoria or
something so anyway and as i listen i
just go like oh my god like you know
this is not this is universal like
basically the chemical of dopamine the
neurotransmitter is the thing that makes
you feel
craving and pleasure when you do things
and it motivates you to do things
and i realized you know basically like
she said you know something along the
lines of if you eat chocolate cake once
a month it tastes amazing
and you don't really crave it that much
you don't really think about it that
much it's very pleasurable if you eat it
once a week
you know it's still enjoyable but it's
not as good and you start having
cravings you start wanting chocolate
cake if you eat it every day
your brain literally craves it and
you're in pain until you eat it and when
you eat it it's not even that enjoyable
it just makes the pain go away for a
little bit and she compares that to like
heroin addiction or anything and so you
know here we all are we're stimulating
ourselves with social media 24 7 we're
constantly taking these hits and the
hits become less and less enjoyable and
she talked about you know she's at
stanford so she's treating students and
she talked about these kids that would
come in
and they're addicted to social media and
video games and they have no motivation
and so she said look i basically
recommend a dopamine fast for four weeks
they can't do any of that stuff they got
to go walk in silence drive in silence
have quiet moments not avoid those
things and i realized that you know i'd
basically done that uh for myself and
that's why i felt better and i you know
i was an addict it's crazy
[Music]
you